[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur verlief welt
heute gibt es mal wieder einen pott
gericht also ein eintopf mit nudeln und
hackfleisch das ganze ist ziemlich
schnell gemacht und vor allem braucht
ihr wirklich nur einen topf ihr habt
ganz wenig geschehen und habe gleich ein
leckeres mittagessen
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten ich
brauche dafür 400 gramm hackfleisch 30
olivenöl eine zwiebel unserer knoblauch
10 50 gramm tomatenmark etwa 800
milliliter gemüse oder fleischbrühe 200
gramm sahne 400 gramm nudeln
ich hab ich noch gewürze chili oregano
kreuzkümmel paprika edelsüß und ein
lorbeerblatt tiefgefrorene erbsen und
grana pagano oder parmesan und etwas
salz und pfeffer das erste was ich jetzt
machen werde ist als ich mache das ganze
ziemlich zeit sparen deswegen schon mal
den topf erwärmen olivenöl dazugeben
hackfleisch kann ich hier anbraten
okay er war noch nicht heißt er war noch
nicht aber er will nicht gleich als
schön früh nicht anbraten und in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die zwiebel und
knoblauchzehen fein hacken
ich habe zwei gesagt nimm 3
[Musik]
dann gebe ich jetzt hier die zwiebel und
knoblauch würfel dazu und bratze einfach
drei bis vier minuten mit an
[Musik]
perfekt ist jetzt kommt hier das
tomatenmark
jetzt mit angebraten
und dann können das direkt mit der
gemüse oder fleisch brühe ablöschen
es gebe jetzt hier erstmal nur 700
milliliter rein weil ich einfach noch
nicht weiß wie viel flüssigkeit die
nudeln gleich aufsaugen werden dann die
sahne dazu die macht das ganze schön
cremig
hier gebe ich jetzt mal noch alle
gewürze dazu und salz und pfeffer beim
salz müsste einfach kaufen je nachdem
wie gewürze gemüse oder fleisch wie eben
schon ist also am besten wirklich
abschmecken und dann die soße erstmal
schön aufkochen lassen
das ist auch gleich passiert die kocht
gleich ich denke rosmarin mit auch super
dazu kaufen
es geht immer noch so viel aus ich weiß
es ist aber nicht viel es wird einfach
nur fein gemahlen und sobald dann die
flüssigkeit kocht die nudeln dazugeben
und das liebe ich einfach weil bei
diesen ort berichten die nudeln in der
flüssigkeit gar werden und dann einfach
den kompletten geschmack einziehen und
aufsaugen und ich wirklich keine extra
arbeit damit habe die nudeln abgießen
den topf zu reinigen
deswegen machen wir richtig spaß jetzt
kommt ihr der deckel drauf
die hitze schalte ich ein bisschen
runter
lasst das ganze jetzt durchziehen und
durch köcheln bis die nudeln fast gar
sind und ich rühre immer mal wieder um
damit einfach nichts auch an klebt aber
wie gesagt einfach jetzt auch
unterstellen und und käse reiben
[Musik]
im extra das glas weg gestanden was
sieht dass mein schneidebrett vom sturm
mosel ist gestorben
perfekte produktplatzierung
[Musik]
ich habe nochmals 200 millilitern
gemüsebrühe dazu ich musste immer wieder
herstellen sonst grenzt an am boden und
ich kann jetzt sogar den hat komplett
ausmachen
denn im großen topf zieht einfach alles
noch gut nach jetzt hier noch den käse
dazu geben
der macht das ganze schön sämig und ich
gebe zum schluss noch die erbsen dazu da
könnt ihr auch frische erbsen nehmen
aber im tk habe ich eigentlich immer
wechselt da guckt mal allein schon die
farbe oder allein schon wegen der farbe
lohnt sich und wenn jetzt andere
nudelsorten nehmt dann probiert es
einfach mal aus mit der wassermenge oder
mit der brühe
denn wie gesagt ich nehme erst mal 200
weniger und guckt dann probier mal und
wenn sie noch sehr hart sind auf jeden
fall noch dazu geben
deckel drauf ich lasse noch mal fünf
minuten nach ziehen und dann wird
probiert
ok jetzt wird probiert und ich finde das
sieht gut aus wenn das du das auch ich
bin sehr gespannt wie es schmeckt also
es riecht schon richtig gut die ganze
zeit ist beim dreh ich muss sagen ich
habe es selber noch nicht so in montauk
macht ja tatsächlich ich mache mir aber
es geht doch fall schnell wir hier
machen so oft ja wort gerechnet
ich habe das nicht im hinterkopf ich
denke dann mache ich halt wenn es
schnell gehen muss nudeln mit beilage
oder aber eigentlich könnte ich auch
dass man nicht probiert und probiert was
ihnen von außen vielleicht nachdem der
probiert hast also danach aber ich bin
sicher trägt also ich glaube ich
schmecke jetzt schon raus dass es zu
wenig chili ist für meine verhältnisse
aber ich koche ich mache ja ich koche
immer mit wenig chili oder gar nicht
mehr
ja brötchen danach und ich glaube wegen
den kindern
für uns ist das ganz okay so das ist ja
schon auch dann eigentlich immer drin so
dass dann ein bisschen was ein problem
ist hätte werden champagner und wenn ja
wie champignons habt macht mit
das mache ich dann für mich rein ja
richtig richtig schön herzhaft ja ich
habe schon ein bisschen kälter am tag
einfangen und schnelles gericht das
einfach richtig satt machte nicht gern
auf holt das finde ich genial wenn
bislang käse materie so was machen so
aus keine ahnung vier zutaten mac user
einfach und das rezept war jetzt als ich
meinen filmen ja nebenher auch noch
sauber aber innerhalb von zehn minuten
hat man alles im top und dann wartet man
noch mal 10 15 minuten nun alles ist
fertig wirklich supergut
ich würde jetzt dazu einfach nur noch
ein salat machen muss frisches obst
frisches und dann kriegt man einfach ein
schönes auch in dessen und damit ein
reifen von clowns setzt mittagessen oder
freuen wir uns jetzt aber drauf also und
es wird auch super finde ich mit veganem
haag funktionssicherheit mit sicherheit
also könne mehr dazu lautet also das ist
genau man kann super auch realisieren
vegane sahne oder kokosmilch zum
beispiel und dann einfach veganes hat
und dann habt ihr auch ein perfektes weg
ganz gericht
also viel spaß beim nachmachen wir
setzen uns mit den anderen an den tisch
und falls ihr weitere einfache rezept
gesehen wird oder wer rezept wünsche
habt schreibt einfach in die kommentare
vielleicht wieder der wecker schon mal
probieren ja wer dabei sein murat den
hinter die kamera
ich weiß nicht ob ich das vielleicht
kann vielleicht nicht ich erinnere mich
an unscharfe sequenzen aus meiner
vergangenheit
also macht gemacht das rezept gibt es
auch sehr dieses blog de oder in einer
kostenlosen app in der tennis welt app
und da können sie ihre zutaten sogar
umrechnen lassen alles ganz digital
müssten nicht mitdenken einfach rechnen
und die einfach zu erstellen könnt ihr
auch und ihr könnt sogar die
einkaufsliste erstellen abhaken was er
schon zu hause hat und dann an jemanden
schicken zum einkaufen und die videos
ist lieblich regen dabei
[Musik]